what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today what are we watching
today john
the trailer for escape room 2 tournament
of champions
you know the other day i was trapped in
a room
i couldn't escape really yeah the
bathroom
someone let me out hello i have to
escape the bathroom what did you do
there was nothing else i could do
so i decided to shave
okay did you follow the clues to escape
the room
no john but what i did realize was that
an electric razor just wasn't good
enough to get my
cheek and neck area and that's when i
found it what did you find
a box of products from harry's i didn't
know whether or not it was the right
razor
but what i did discover was that harry's
is a personal care brand that delivers a
close
comfortable shave at a fair price as low
as two dollars per blade refill
well that's convenient because they're
today's video sponsor
yeah i don't care about that what i did
care about was my discovery
imagine it john the razor has a weighted
handle with a textured rubber grip to
prevent slippage
and harry's even makes an awesome
foaming shave gel that's suitable for
rugged
and sensitive skin alike and you know
what else john
being trapped in there wasn't good for
my mental health either that's when i
also discovered
when you buy from harry's you're also
supporting some great causes
they give a percentage of their global
sales to non-profit organizations for
mental health care
for those in need and being trapped in
that room for so long
i realized i never want to leave this
home ever again
which is great because you can grab
harry's with or without subscription
and they'll send the blades right to
your door and john what
you're gonna be a father soon i learned
this in the bathroom they even got gift
sets
if you're looking for that perfect
father's day present and you can redeem
your trial set for just three dollars
and get five dollars off
any shave product when you visit
harrys.com
the real rejects how did you get out of
the bathroom
like any good escape room i followed the
clues
uh never mind i got it i got it
hey look at that we changed clothes
thank you for coming with me
no way
[Music]
oh no
you poor sons of [ __ ] you guys have
played the game before
so what is this like a tournament of
champions
ha the title
some kind of suicide squad this ad
yourself is missing me so maybe we pull
the corresponding handles with a missing
letter
yes
[Music]
this feels more like saw than ever yeah
like really saw and cube
just yeah oh yeah it is
no my dude
ah
this is so insane this is so crazy
whoa
yes
i hope this is not the end of it that's
not yeah the final scene of the new
year's i get a big vibe that's the very
end of the movie
or like the finale right there nah
that's the beginning they're gonna trick
you all around and then it turns out
that this was taking place on didn't
they get on a plane at the end of the
last movie like this is a direct sequel
although i feel like that
has been recontextualized here i don't
think we reviewed the first one
but we did see it in the theaters i
remember being surprised by how much i
was enjoying the movie i thought i
completely fell apart in like the last
15 12. that's when i thought it was like
oh okay this movie just
totally lost me and then he just got
bombarded huge
twists and [ __ ] i was like too much too
much
and it was so i thought it was really
dumb in the last like 15 20 minutes
the journey for most of it i thought was
surprisingly enjoyable the stages were
pretty well developed it is more like
elaborate sci-fi
version of a saw movie it's just not as
violent as pg-13 it's a pg-13 version of
cube yeah yeah essentially yeah and
uh when the trailer started i think the
thing that surprised you the most
was oh i thought you would just like
start over
yeah do a new cast pretty much similar
setup but apparently they got an actual
storyline they
really want to fulfill with their
characters and
to me in some ways that kind of
separates it from so i wasn't expecting
that i really thought they'd be starting
fresh
and then it's just it's way crazier and
way more unbelievable and way more
unrealistic
and it's kind of funny how sony who also
is doing venom
seem to know what worked about the first
one and is honing in more on
that type of tone and humor and whatnot
here with escape room it looks like
they're kind of doing the same thing
people seem to like how big it was and
how crazy it was
i i think they were like let's just try
to top ourselves with the set pieces
this time around because yeah that's
essentially the vibe that i'm getting
here
i feel like that's the way to go with it
yeah and it's funny because i kind of
kind of got the opposite vibe
in that i was like oh this is even more
like saw because now they're gonna go on
like a full-on continuity and they're
gonna keep certain characters and
they're just gonna keep this
one storyline going i'm talking about
the victims that played the game though
you know oh yeah yeah like where the
next movie is picking up immediately
yeah
of champions would be like a five or
sixth installment
yeah we actually have some champions to
bring back who weren't just in the first
movie
actually come to think of it john's
right they brought back amanda and saw
two and she was a victim of the first
saw movie
so yeah yeah yeah yeah
it does look like blockbuster saw which
again was part of the charm of the first
one and the first one is one of those to
me kind of quintessential it's got like
a 51 on rotten tomatoes you either
like it or you really don't like it you
think it's dumb and i feel like yeah
they're honing in on the ridiculousness
that much more and it seems like they're
willing to spend some of that money on
the ridiculousness so now yeah it's like
they're were in
vr simulations with screens all around
yeah
nothing is real and then the only thing
that that really makes me wonder
is adam robitaille i think his direction
is really punchy like i liked this sort
of
you know it's like a pulp movie but at
the same time it's got some grit to it
of the first one and so now i just hope
that i'm not going to spend this movie
missing that r well especially when you
got a character who literally puts your
hand on a spiral uh
yeah but this character who can't feel
pain
like you could do so many gross things
with a person all the groceries yeah
every grocery you can make this person
suffer the worst of consequences
in a situation like that it looks a lot
more punchy
the rhythm feels like a lot more like
pulsating
whereas the first one had more of a
build to it yeah this is like we're slam
bam you're in a subway we know where we
are
craziness yeah let's go you know we
already know they have we spend too much
time trying to pretend like we're
starting off in the real world you're
just gonna be looking
for the clues yeah they seem like they
have no interest in realism this time
right now
yeah let's just get bigger than like
yeah nerve or any of those other movies
let's go full-on blockbuster but hey
guys what'd you think of this trailer
are you going to see escape room
2 tournament of champions leave your
thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell thank you
to harry's for sponsoring
this video and letting us do a wacky ad
catch you guys soon